i got started in high school i've always
been in a tech
and i was buying a laptop long story
short i watched a bunch of videos about
all these laptops to buy
finally got one and there's there's some
stuff i didn't see in those videos
so what felt natural was to turn the
camera on myself and make a video
about those things
[Music]
my name is marquez brownlee aka mkbhd on
the internet so i make tech
videos reviews it all started with
trying to make what i would want to
watch and i think that
fundamental philosophy has carried
itself through every every decision i've
made which has turned it into a brand
and a vision moving forward
every time we're trying to decide as a
team because i have a small team that
helps in videos
do we want to do this or not do we want
to review this or not do we want to
change this or not the question we
always come back to is
well as a viewer if i was subscribed
what would i want to see what would i
enjoy
what would help me the most and that
sort of stayed
our true north through the whole thing
they say when you turn your hobby into
your job you never work a day in your
life
that's part true that's also part not
true and it's easy to fall into that
trap
because i hear a lot of people and
especially now saying oh my kid wants to
be a youtuber
or my kid wants to be a social media
person
and you can want to be that and that's
fine but you have to want that for the
right reasons you want to actually have
a passion for
whether it's tech or makeup or cars or
whatever it is
over time eventually it can grow and it
can become
the things you see on youtube and on
instagram and on tiktok for that matter
but my advice would be pick something
you can actually make
and and pour hours into and have a lot
of fun with even if it never turns into
this incredibly rare success story
you